[Musica]
buongiorno come state
allora solitamente quando si viene un
telex si viene per riflettere per
ascoltare io credo che soddisferò
parzialmente questa vostra aspettativa
perché vi chiederò come farebbe un
nuotatore una virata energica verso di
voi e che spostasse l'attenzione proprio
sulla vostra persona qualcuno potrebbe
dire ma cosa ci sta dicendo lo facciamo
di continuo in realtà l'ascolto quello
autentico è qualcosa che non facciamo
così spesso è nemmeno automatico se
penso alla mia pratica clinica come
psicoterapeuta piuttosto che alla mia
quotidianità
io incontro un sacco di persone che si
lamentano del fatto di non sentirsi
ascoltate e l'amica perché parla sempre
lei il marito il fidanzato perché
e voi l'avete capito cosa fanno gli
uomini mentre noi parliamo
resta un mistero comunque spendiamo anzi
direi perdiamo un sacco di tempo a
chiederci e ad aspettarci qualcosa dagli
altri piuttosto che pensare a quello che
noi possiamo fare per noi stessi
allora io vorrei fin da subito
cominciare a fare questa cosa con voi e
quindi faremo una sorta di gioco di
esperimento tra breve vi chiederò di
alzarvi in piedi di mettervi a coppie
l'uno di fronte all'altro e di
appoggiare le mani sulla persona che vi
sta di fronte
come vi state sentendo all'idea
proviamo a percepire le eventuali
tensioni o cambiamenti corporei
proviamo ad ascoltare le emozioni che
stiamo provando magari qualcuno se un po
agitato all'idea qualcuno è rimasto
tranquillo qualcuno è sorpreso
adesso vi chiedo di fare un passaggio
ulteriore ancora più complicato in un
certo senso vi chiedo che cos'è che vi è
passato per la testa nel momento in cui
io vi ho chiesto che avremmo fatto
questa cosa
proviamo a recuperare quel cricetino che
si è messo in moto forse per qualche
donna anche più criceti probabilmente no
perché noi sappiamo che noi donne
rimaste lavatrici sempre in funzione
quindi proviamo a catturare quel criceto
allora mi piacerebbe un sacco proprio
riuscire a sentire ognuno di voi per
capire che cosa vi è passato per la
testa per ovvi motivi non posso farlo e
quindi lavoro un po di immaginazione
allora posso pensare che la persona alla
quale
la quale si è sentita in ansia avrà
pensato oddio ma c'è il covip non si può
fare non ci si può toccare quella che
invece è rimasta sorpresa avrà pensato a
ma perché si può fare è la persona che
invece è rimasta totalmente tranquilla
avrà detto bobo facciamo sta cosa
la persona invece entusiasta avrà detto
che bello finalmente ci si tocca quindi
probabilmente poi a seconda di ciò che
vi sta succedendo dice che state
pensando agirete in maniera diversa
magari qualcuno con la scusa della pipì
va in bagno
qualcuno si distrae cercando qualcosa
nella borsa
qualcuno magari fa la cosa primati io
glielo dica ok quindi si intrecciano no
queste cose e per farvelo capire meglio
vi racconto di una persona che io
conosco molto bene la sottoscritta
allora io ho fatto per quasi 15 anni
nuoto ad alto livello sono stata pluri
campionessa nazionale di categoria nello
stile libero poi ho smesso
probabilmente per un anno non mi faceva
nemmeno la doccia pur di non toccare
l'acqua dopo mi sono armata di coraggio
mi sono riavvicinata le piscine o mi
sono buttata nel mondo della pallanuoto
e a 23 anni ho avuto l'opportunità di
militare nella massima categoria in
serie a
per questo motivo proprio quell età mi
sono trasferita in sicilia e
alle prime partite di serie a ai miei
esordi un inferno ma non perché le
partite fossero un inferno
ero io renderle tali e perché
perché i miei criceti son donna quindi
no tanti continuavano a ricordarmi il
fatto che mi stavo letteralmente
scontrando con delle giocatrici
olimpioniche la mia attenzione era
completamente focalizzata sul fatto che
non potevo farcela e non ero in grado
erano più forti di me e bla bla bla
come potevo sentirmi ansia agitazione e
nervosismo
i miei muscoli parlavano la stessa
lingua e la prestazione come poteva
essere secondo voi certamente al di
sotto delle mie possibilità
quindi andavo a creare un maledetto
circolo vizioso perché perché poi non
giocavo bene la prestazione era scadente
e questo andava confermarmi che la mia
convinzione di non essere in grado è
solo dei circoli viziosi tremendi è e da
dove nascono forse stiamo cominciando a
capirlo l'incipit air è proprio quel
criceto che noi mettiamo in moto
mica finita per voi adesso vi richiamo
in gioco vi faccio immaginare un'altra
situazione
devo raggiungere un posto che non
conosco sono per strada
ciò il mio tomtom cioè mio cellulare non
si sa mai
tomtom smette di funzionare cellulare
non c'è campo
panico o quei criceti allora
probabilmente la maggior parte di voi o
qualcuno di voi piuttosto di fermarsi e
chiedere informazioni preferisce puntare
a un guard rail
qualcun'altro i più coraggiosi
dopo che sono passate almeno 23 persone
che avete scartato per i motivi più
disparati alla ventiquattresima vi
fermate via armate di coraggio tirate
giù il finestrino e già li immaginate di
arrivare poi a casa e dire a vostro
figlio figlio ce l'ho fatto chiesto
informazioni quindi supereroe
finalmente anche il papa è un supereroe
ho tirato giù il finestrino chiedo
informazioni chissà in che modo è la
risposta della persona poi cosa sarà non
sono del posto è un classico ma non
dobbiamo scomodare la legge di murphy
probabilmente abbiamo scelto quella
persona perché in quel volto abbiamo
riconosciuto lo stesso sguardo perso
impaurito che avevamo in quel momento
quindi come vedete tutto è nato da ciò
che io ho letto no dall'interpretazione
che io ho fatto delle cose dal mio
pensiero del mio criceto che mi avrà
fatto sentire in un certo modo e quindi
poi agire in un modo più o meno efficace
e socialmente accettabile ma perché
certi hanno dei criceti fighi e altri
invece hanno dei criceti sfigati doppi
canti allora la risposta è duplice e
quindi penso un po al mondo dello sport
è un po come l'atleta che da una parte
frutto di un talento quindi di una
predisposizione verso una certa cosa
parte minima e dall'altra frutto di
tutto ciò che impara in acqua in pista
sul campo da un punto di vista tattico
tecnico fisico mentale allo stesso modo
ognuno di noi è frutto di una
predisposizione quindi ciò che madre
natura ha scelto per noi il dna e la
stragrande maggioranza è frutto di tutti
quei condizionamenti ed apprendimenti
che noi riceviamo nel corso della nostra
vita soprattutto nei primi anni
adolescenza compresa quando siamo delle
spugne che assorbiamo assorbiamo
assorbiamo prendiamo quindi
condizionamenti familiari sociali
sportivi amicali qualsiasi contesto ci
insegna ci trasmette qualcosa e poi si
trasforma nel nostro modo di di reagire
alle cose di pensare alle cose c'è una
bella notizia
ci deve essere
se noi siamo per la stragrande
maggioranza di cose frutto dei nostri
apprendimenti se ciò che abbiamo appreso
ci fa agire male ci fa sentire male ci
fa funzionare male non ci fa raggiungere
i nostri obiettivi disimpariamo e
impareremo dei nuovi modi di funzionare
di reagire di fronte agli eventi e
questa è tanta roba
è quello che ho imparato a fare anch'io
e quindi ripenso a quella
daniela che alle prime partite di
pallanuoto
quando era una corda di violino è
probabilmente faceva percepire questa
cosa anche all'esterno
e un giorno il mio allenatore che ha
ancora porto nel mio cuore mi prese da
parte e mi guardò e mi disse hanno due
gambe e due braccia come te a me questa
cosa aprì un mondo apparentemente banale
però mi diede l'avvio per cominciare a
vedere le cose in maniera diversa e
quindi cominciai a focalizzarmi sui miei
punti di forza
la velocità il mio essere spigolosa il
fatto che ero che fossi mancina che ha
un valore aggiunto in uno sport come
questo quindi quello unito poi alle
parti alle parole della mia portiera
canadese che un giorno prima di una
partita probabilmente sentendo il rumore
dei criceti mi guardò e mi disse stop
thinking
questo per me fu veramente l'avvio di un
nuovo modo di vedere e di vedermi
chiaramente anche il mio stato emotivo e
fisico cambiò e la prestazione cominciò
corrispondere a quello che io potevo
veramente fare e dare quindi dipende da
me dipende da noi il tempo il meteo lo
subiamo ma come noi decidiamo di pensare
alle cose di percepire le cose è sotto
il nostro controllo
ci vuole allenamento mentale come un
atleta allena la sua tecnica la sua
tattica il suo fisico per diventare più
veloce più preciso a seconda dello sport
lo stesso modo ognuno di noi può
allenare la propria mente per cominciare
a sentirsi e quindi ad agire in maniera
diversa
allenamento mentale
dipende da noi
prima di salutarvi vi vorrei lasciare
con un primo strumento di lavoro
un po come abbiamo fatto oggi
quando ci capita di sentirci in ansia
tesi arrabbiati frustrati infastiditi
fermiamoci e chiediamoci che cos'è che
mi è passato per la testa
io credo che la maggior parte delle
volte la risposta riusciamo a
recuperarla per quanto quel velo quel
pensiero sia veloce trovata la risposta
facciamoci quest'ulteriore domanda ma in
fondo cosa c'è di così terribile in
questo la stragrande maggioranza di
volte io sono certa che anche qui la
risposta sarà nulla e questo può essere
l'inizio del vostro cambiamento e allora
buon allenamento mentale
[Applauso]